now his bid to make space travel more
accessible is well known but now Sir
Richard Branson is hoping to reinvent
what astronauts wear to the co-founder
of Virgin Galactic has just unveiled a
spacesuit or a space where system
created specifically for private
astronauts the outfit is made up of a
base layer spacesuit footwear a training
suit and an astronaut jacket and
unveiling the new look is the company's
latest step in its effort to launch of
course commercial operations pretty soon
we'll I'm joy now at life New York by
Sir Richard Branson the co-founder of
Virgin Galactic thanks very much for
joining us so you want your paying
customers to experience space and
weightlessness but also to look good at
the same time is that it absolutely I
think it's a it's a total experience is
going to most magnificent spaceport in
the world is getting looking at the
white knight - that is beautiful sexy
craft that will take the space ship
which is equally sexy craft up into
space and if you're gonna do something
like this you might as well feel good
look good feel comfortable feel more
feel you know deal deal with the heat
and and when you're in space and you
want to be able to float around and not
have a space suit that's going to be
constricting so Under Armour who've done
this for us they spent two years working
on it and they've done a fantastic job
and we and all our astronauts are
incredibly happy about it right and I
guess that's included in the in the cost
is it you know the two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars or whatever it is that
it's including the ticket price I hope
yeah if you if you if you if sky pay you
well enough and if you buy a ticket
we'll throw in the spacesuit as part of
that and the boots the boots of really
nice boots
absolutely so space tourism Sir Richard
has had many false dawn
you've had a number of test flights more
recently after the tragic accident in
2014 how close are you do you think now
to making the first commercial trip
we've had an incredible few months we've
got we put five people into space to
test our spaceship I went to put that in
perspective they were all made
astronauts and the last astronaut that
was made on American soil and that's
including NASA was in 2009 so and so I
think we're the only spaceship company
there's putting people into space at the
moment you know NASA used our spaceships
to put big big loads of scientific
experiments on it on our flights and so
we're now moving the whole operation to
the spaceport in New Mexico that and and
you know moving the staff they're moving
in the mothership they're soon to move
the spaceship there then we'll do a few
more test flights and then next year
I'll go up and and we'll start putting
people up because people are pushing you
but Elon Musk is trying to do something
Jeff B sauces up to something do you
think you will be the first to do this
on it one of these commercial flights
well I think that I mean you know I'm
gonna we are the only spaceship company
including what Elon is doing and what
Jeff is doing to put five people into
space and I mean they put craft into
space but no people and so I think you
know in a sense we have already proven
that we are ahead in the race to space
as far as people's concerned what
they're doing is it is extraordinary in
a different way and have enormous
respect for both of them and you know
we'll all be doing different things to
do with space and in a different
slightly different ways and how long do
you think it'll be before you know it
becomes the price comes down
sufficiently
for you know more people to do it and
you know how long before flights perhaps
to the moon or another planet so I think
as we build new spaceships we'll be able
to bring the price down and the more
spaceships we build the more we'll be
able to bring the price down and and
based on you know we've already got 600
people signed up we've got another 3,000
on a waiting list so there's there's
numerous people who want to go the
initial people will will go at the
slightly higher price and that will help
pay back for the hundreds of millions
that we put into the venture and then in
time the price will come down now as far
as other things in space are concerned
you know we have other announcements to
make over the next few months which are
going to be very exciting obviously you
know we want one day we'd love to put
people into orbit we love maybe you know
to go to the space station we might we
might even you know build a small hotel
in space and and yeah there's a lot of
things you know also deep deep probes
they weren't necessary well we all have
people on we've got virgin orbiter which
aren't rocket that we launch in front of
747 they can put deep probes into space
and I think one of the most exquisite
pictures I've seen was a picture of a
new planet that's been discovered which
just looks like I mean it's full of
water tremendously exciting and you know
be wonderful to get probes to places
like that to see if there's any life on
it as well yeah look I hate to bring you
back down to earth very finely but the
quick word on bricks it looks like
there's a deal going to be done still
talk of a possible second referendum
where are you on all this now and do
would you support a deal if it meant you
know avoiding No Deal and means we get
on with it but no there's no question
that no deal would have been an
unmitigated disaster for Great Britain
and wouldn't have been great for Europe
I mean I personally think that whatever
you know whatever is negotiated should
go to the public for a final decision
and the and and you know when we when
the original referendum was done you
know I think all the difficulties of
leaving Europe were not clear to people
I think there must be clear to people by
now and so I mean in an ideal world I'd
love I'd love to see what whatever deals
been negotiated go to a second
referendum and then you know we put it
to bed once and for all but at least
people are voting on specific facts on
the table rather than promises which
have been proven not to have come true
all right sir Richard thanks very much